your mind might not remember what
happened in that room
but your body does
episode 1 of 1899 opens with the
character Mara Franklin reading the
first two stanzas of the Emily Dickinson
poem the brain is wider than the sky the
idea behind that is that even though the
human brain in the mind that exists
within it are much smaller physically
than the sky or the ocean it can contain
them it's about the magnitude of the
mind's capacity to create or to imagine
or to perceive or to remember the new
show from the creators of dark uses its
first Eight Episodes to examine what the
mind's capable of and the way it
connects us to our perception of reality
as the story unfolds there are several
references to Plato's allegory of the
cave to drive this point home very
simply put that is about how what we
perceive to be real from our experience
can be totally different from true
knowledge or understanding the series
starts out as what feels like a direct
homage to the show Lost it puts a bunch
of people who don't know each other
together in a crisis situation and then
slowly reveals details through
flashbacks about what shaped them into
being who they are in that moment it
examines how they choose to present
themselves What secrets they decide to
keep hidden and who they would decide to
be if things were to get crazy it's not
just that by any means 1899's characters
don't end up on an island after a plane
crash instead they're on a steamship on
route to Fresh Starts in the new world
it's a large cast of Mostly Europeans
who are diverse in culture class and the
languages they speak the catch is that
by the end you're left scratching your
head as to whether anything we learned
about these characters was true and we
will come back around to that at the end
of this video but before I get into what
happens I do want to address the idea of
things taking place in a simulation
because I think it'll be divisive I'm a
big fan of sci-fi and all the
imagination that goes along with that
which means that over the last few years
of making videos about TV shows
especially ones where it's obvious
things aren't exactly as they seem one
of the first theories that always pops
up is that they're in a simulation every
time I see it my internal response is oh
please don't let it be that because in
theory when you end that way it kind of
diminishes everything that happened on
the way to get to that place here I'm
still willing to give the creators the
benefit of the doubt I think this could
be a creative decision that comes from a
place of understanding that and looking
at it as a challenge they could take on
we'll have to wait and see but the more
I sit with this ending the more I like
that possibility at the same time it
does make my job a little more
complicated in relation to recapping the
first six and a half episodes were there
an amazing amount of details that will
likely be important going forward if it
gets picked up for a second season
absolutely are any of those crucial in
understanding the ending of season one
it's hard to tell all if the president
is 2099 and that's a big if in a story
that is obsessed with our relationship
to reality then all of the memories that
take place in the 19th century are
almost certainly false or tied to
something that happened to these
characters at a different time
altogether also Elliot Daniel and Henry
all exist in the simulation they appear
to understand what's going on there
after being through it so many times but
they're all noticeably absent in the
final scene in the spaceship so there's
no telling if any of them are still
alive or even exist in the present what
we do know is that the characters in
1899 are in a simulation that takes
place on a ship called the Kerberos
making that Journey to the United States
the thing that they all seem to have in
common is that they're trying to leave
their past lives behind in one way or
another they all seem to be running from
something we'll learn later that they're
actually stuck in a loop that forces
them to experience painful memories with
more are being the exception since she
seems to have forgotten hers she
believes her father Henry did something
to make her forget and we see a
recurring memory surface of her being
strapped to a chair and given an
injection in her neck over time it's
revealed that there are three passengers
who know more about what's going on than
everyone else Daniel Elliott and the
ship's first mate Sebastian that last
one is working with Henry while the
other two appear to be working against
him the first mate is there from the
beginning pulling some strings behind
the scenes while Daniel makes his way
onto the ship from the Prometheus when
they go to investigate that and Elliot
is discovered there as well Daniel tells
Mara he's her husband and that Elliot is
their son but she doesn't have any
memory of their time together we do get
to see some of their memories though and
it's worth noting that she's in them I
guess I should say that because it's a
simulation that everything was created
the ship and everything contained within
is a manifestation of code while that
means it's not real it doesn't mean that
it won't turn out to be symbolic or even
crucial to understanding the truth of
what's Happening down the road for a
quick example of how that works think of
the two syringes that are in room 1011
in the mental hospital initially the
white one makes you remember and the
black one makes you forget but when
Daniel starts messing with the code the
black one sends Mara to the chamber
under the grave instead so while it's
all made up it may just turn out to be a
place Mara's brother Kieran is trying to
keep everyone for eternity I don't think
we should write off all the potential
clues that exist in all of the episodes
that take place in the simulation even
if we take it at face value that Kieran
is a person that exists in reality that
has different motivations than Mara and
has co-opted the simulation she designed
that doesn't tell us much about why she
decided on the specifics of the
simulation the steamer traveling to the
new world centuries in the past or for
that matter why she tried to erase her
memories in the first place one of the
show's big twists was that despite the
reveal of the modernish looking monitors
at the end of episode 2 and the needle
drop of Black Sabbath the wizard at the
end of episode 5. Henry was not the
simulation's Creator I'm guessing most
of what Mara says about his experiments
and his past are based in reality but
according to what Daniel tells her at
the end it appears that they are the
ones who were creating the simulations
Apparently at some point in his
childhood Elliot started to die and Mara
looked to technology for a way to keep
him alive forever they never come out
and say it but the grave and the fact
that she seems to be trying to forget
something traumatic appear to indicate
that Elliot did die with Daniel and
Henry it's a little harder to tell as I
mentioned neither one of them were
present in the spaceship when Mara wakes
up and the simulation Daniel has
knowledge about things outside of it he
wanted Mara to wake up because he said
her brother had taken over the
simulation and he hinted that there was
more to that when he said this is bigger
than you think the one thing that makes
me think that he might be dead or that
he may only exist in the simulation is
that when she asked if he'll be there
when she wakes up he says always which
sounds a lot more like a reference to
their conversation in his memory when
they were talking about how everything
you've known or experienced is all in
your brain somewhere it sounded like he
was saying that he would always be in
her memory rather than him saying that
he would be there in the next pod down
the hall or whatever Henry on the other
hand was actively trying to get the key
so he could wake up and with nothing
else to go on Beyond his fear of being
stuck in there at least for now I'm
guessing he does exist in reality
regardless if Daniel is still out there
somewhere in the real world he's able to
create a virus to corrupt the simulation
which is represented by those black
growths that start popping up everywhere
and ultimately rewrite the code to stop
Henry's attempt at waking up and
allowing Mara to do that first as far as
we understand at the end the simulation
is destroyed or at least it didn't
complete the loop to start over like it
had in the past what that mean means for
those who were left behind is a big
question going forward I brought up the
Emily Dickinson poem in the beginning
and I find it interesting that she
doesn't read the third and final stanza
which says the brain is just the weight
of God for half them pound for pound and
they will differ if they do as syllable
from sound that brings to mind the idea
of a Creator the idea that the brain has
the same capacity to create that God
does and with the simulation you can't
help but think about playing God we can
mostly piece together that Mara tried to
use what she knew about the mind to
create a place where she could forget
and be rid of the pain she was
experiencing Henry tells Elliot that
this is impossible as much as we try to
forget what we don't want to remember
we'll never be able to delete our
memories entirely they're a part of who
we are woven into our very fabric he
goes on to tell him that even if they
delete the memories in this simulation
their senses are still reacting to the
same trick Tigers the Mind might not
remember what happened but the body does
he explains that the simulation isn't a
prison that his mother is trapped in but
one that was built for him and he makes
it explicit that Elliot is trapped in
this simulation so his mother can keep
him alive and while I don't think we
should accept everything he says as
truth we don't know what his motivations
are Beyond trying to get the key and he
did seem kind of shady once he had it
but this all does seem to track with
Daniel's memory of the conversation he
had with Mara in episode 7. he Echoes
that same idea that one's whole reality
is actually inside one's mind that none
of what we know as reality would exist
without the Mind experiencing it we'll
never know if the stimuli in our brain
are caused by reality or a construct of
one and when you start to talk about it
like that you start to get into the
territory of what is the difference of
living in reality or in a simulation in
both conversations the idea of Plato's
Cave is brought up and Henry tells
Elliot that his mother's world was
turned upside down by the idea that our
knowledge has limits what she came to
from reading the allegory and that we
can never know if things truly are how
they appear he uses the example of God
being the creator of our reality and her
response to that that if that were true
then the world that God lives in would
be the real one and we're just his
doll's house in their conversation
Daniel tells her that in the simulation
she's like the prisoners in Plato's Cave
looking at Shadows on the wall and he
wants her to be able to look over her
shoulder and see where the light is
coming from by the end Henry helps her
to do that even if she doesn't believe
him he gets the key and he tries to
start the cycle of her for getting over
again and learns that Daniel rewrote the
code Mara is transported to the child's
room beneath the grave which he tells
her is the first simulation they created
together everything about it seems
consistent with them losing their child
and wanting to have a place to remember
him but it doesn't really tell us
anything about how they got from there
to what is happening on the Kerberos in
that traumatic Loop either way for now
she seems to have broken free from that
she wakes up inside a chamber in a
spaceship that appears to house several
identical ones most of the important
characters she met on the ship are there
with her she sees a card with the phrase
may your coffee kick in before reality
does which sounds like something your
uncle might have printed on his favorite
coffee mug and that phrase being printed
in all the books was one of the clues
that they were in a simulation before
that was revealed on a not very
futuristic computer screen we see the
name project Prometheus we learned that
the date is October 19
2099 and that there are
1923 passengers and crew on what is
described as a survival Mission she
reads a message from her brother
welcoming her back to reality and the
look on her face doesn't exactly scream
okay now I remember what's going on and
we see the repeated motif of the
triangle or the pyramid in her eyeball
as we zoom in and the season ends right
there there are a lot of obvious
parallels between the Kerberos and this
survival Mission and the same way I had
the knee-jerk reaction of don't let this
be a simulation on the first ship I
immediately thought don't let this be
another layer to the simulation I guess
it's just the way I think but after
making peace with that first choice I
almost have to just strap myself in for
the ride now that we're here could it be
reality could this all be taking place
on a spaceship in 2099 absolutely on the
surface it's just a long-haul transport
that puts passengers in stasis so that
they can survive on a trip that would
last hundreds of years this is something
that you read about in sci-fi quite a
bit they would just have to connect a
few dots to explain how Mara's desire to
create a place to remember Elliot got
tied into this seemingly unrelated
Endeavor but if what Daniel said about
Kieran taking over the project for
nefarious purposes was true then I would
say it's a 50 50 chance that he's lying
to her about being awake in reality the
one item that might support the idea
that everyone is on a survival mission
to escape a dying Earth or something
along those lines is the repeated use of
the symbol of the triangle pointing down
with a line through it this is the
alchemical symbol for Earth and we saw
it all over the place in the design of
the simulation and the marketing
materials for the show and the last
scene we even see that she has a tattoo
of it behind her ear just like the one
she found on Elliot that's enough to add
to the mystery but I can't help but
think about that line from dark what we
know is a drop what we don't know is an
ocean and we're probably still not
asking the right questions which should
make for some fun theories while we wait
for season two so I did really enjoy the
show maybe not in the same way I enjoyed
dark when I first discovered that but
but I haven't been able to stop thinking
about it I think the shows introduced
their mysteries in very different ways
dark had The Disappearance of Eric and
Michael something that was grounded in
the characters and how they were
connected in that little town and then
it expanded from there 1899's characters
are connected in their desire to run
from something but not by much else
other than they're in a confined space
together they all have secrets and
they're naturally suspicious of each
other and that's before you factor in
their inability to communicate I know
the creators were really excited about
making a truly International show with
these different languages and I like the
idea but in practice you do lose some of
what you can do with them since so much
of their interactions are just not being
able to understand each other it creates
some interesting Dynamics like at the
end none of them could talk to each
other really but when you add in that
idea that these memories we've watched
them revisit are probably false like the
things that made them who we thought
they were leading into the finale it
does start to feel like you're taking
some risks but I don't think there's
anything wrong with that if you have a
plan that you think you can pull off as
much as I love dark I want to see what
else they can do and I would rather see
creatives air on the side of Taking
Chances there's a chance that it might
not work but you also get a better
reward when it does I wasn't pulled into
this world in the same way I was to win
then but these characters are starting
in a different place it's a different
feeling it's asking a lot of interesting
questions about how we perceive the
world around us how there is so much
that's outside of our control even when
we understand what's going on and how
hard it can be to let go of things even
when you know it's the right thing to do
as a TV show I think it's impressive on
a few different levels the
cinematography Direction and The
intentional writing are things we
already knew they could do and those are
all still there and the performances
came came through when the situation
called for it the emphasis on the puzzle
made it so that some of the characters
didn't have much to do but they all had
some things that they can build on in
future Seasons I thought the score was a
little dialed back compared to dark I
mean that show had so much atmosphere
but I thought that gave it more weight
when it did kick in one thing that I
really liked was the way they went about
revealing things they kept the audience
on the same Pace as the characters and
putting the viewers in a situation where
you pretty much know what's going on but
you just don't want to believe it yet
felt very deliberate and just a great
touch if you're planning on turning
things on their head I do have a lot of
questions so many that I think I'd
rather get into those in a separate
video there are also a lot of details I
want to go back and take a closer look
at so be on the lookout for some more
videos this week we're in the same place
as the main character right now we don't
know how much of what we're experiencing
is real or what to believe I guess not
in in the exact same place because if we
can believe Henry and her turn at
playing God she tried to create a place
where she could do the impossible and
forget there's probably a lot more going
on and I'm looking forward to finding
out and I think that's a great place to
leave things
let me know in the comments what you
thought about the season what was your
favorite episode I think I probably got
hooked in at the end of episode two I
was a little disoriented with things
maybe for the first couple but from
there I was pretty much like okay I want
to figure out what's going on here the
simulation effect is a little bit
strange considering how important every
single detail felt in dark like I said I
don't love this idea I'd be happy to be
proven wrong and I would be impressed if
they looked at this as a challenge they
thought they could tackle and they do
manage to pull it off please like this
video If you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon